and freakling brothers horror shows are
back for their 30th year of Haunting and
we send Rocky to see what's new behind
the Gates of Hell lucky you Rocky how's
it going
oh JC if you guys can see my forehead I
am sweating and Warren here you said
there is no air conditioner in hell
right so
freak me out let's talk you have been a
part of the Horror history of Las Vegas
for a long time tell everybody your
background uh frequent Brothers started
commercially in 92 and I've been with
him since two resonate this is my 15th
year okay I used to be a performer here
and now they've got the little ticks
running this out okay great well
speaking of lunatics running the asylums
take me through let's go I heard it's
Judgment Day what does that mean here
with the frickling brothers well all of
our shows have a new hot a new room this
year and this is judgment
oh what happens in judgment well you
just have to come and see but you do get
judged for the final time so what's
what's give me an example of something
someone would get judged for here
witchcraft okay all right I'm enough
everybody's found guilty
I said
on the lot right each of our shows have
at least one new scene this year okay
and this is the new scene one of the new
scenes here at Kevin of 13. okay where
are we headed now we're headed to see
Rosemary
I don't like that name who is Rosemary
okay
come over here with me Rocky you should
be safe over here don't get too close
what's happening in the Rosemary is she
pregnant yes Rosemary is about to give
birth to one of our new coven members
okay oh God bless your heart Rosemary
okay tell everybody how they can come
down and visit you guys I know it's not
all October long they've got to come in
the at the right time correct we open
this Thursday we'll be open through
Sunday and then we'll be open again
October 13th every single night through
Halloween okay guys come on down we're
near the I can't tell everybody how they
can come see you uh we're in the Ikea
parking lot our chicken Booth opens at
seven o'clock nightly and the shows
start at 7 30. Warren I I would say
thank you but I am not thankful for this
visual I'll put it back to you guys oh
oh bless your heart Rocky for being the
one handling this story thank you so
much we appreciate it well